the Joe Rogan experience it's
interesting to see you even just [ __ ]
around with your skateboard just the way
you maneuver it so you're so adept it's
really weird like you the way you move
your feet and just pick it up and oh I
mean it really is just at this point
kind of extension to my body it seems
like and it's I guess it's weird I don't
think about how comfortable I am and a
lot of times we'll be in a city or
something or just like now I didn't know
where to park right so I just parked
somewhere kind of close and just I go
skate and I feel way better about doing
that than like parking and then walking
somewhere and just you know I know I can
get around people and sort of be
indiscreet and and stealthy with
indiscreet tone I'm just saying like a
port is in this creature yeah then I
guess a lot of do a kick flips out from
car window really yeah that's funny yeah
that's my curse that I that I that's my
burden I carry I've seen these new
skateboards that are they look like
convertibles whereas these guys flip the
board the wheels flip up and go down
yeah that's that's sort of a phenomenon
sort of a social media thing going on so
you can see it in slow-mo is that what
it is know where the board is actually a
contraption right yeah I don't I don't
really understand what that is there's
there's a select few people doing that
yeah and I've seen a couple where they
actually have figured out how to make
their board grind and then do a flip
around a rail as they jump back on it oh
boy
yeah that's it's very specialized though
I can't say that's a movement it's just
a few key people who do many bones do
you have to break to perfect what is
dude sliding down rails I'm like how
many times do you [ __ ] that up yeah
before arm I while skating went through
a different different waves of
disciplines basically and in the early
90s it was all Street right and so what
I did was was vert skating that was kind
of dying out so I I was skating Street a
lot too and I realized I was not fit to
be a street skater the third time I
rolled my ankle like both ankles twice
then the third time the other one I was
like I don't want two handrails and
this is not working for me this impact
is I'm not gonna be able to skate
anymore if I keep doing this I see these
kids like whenever you go like near like
a large office building that has a lot
of outdoor space and you see them using
the rails and stuff like how many breaks
can you have before like I there I think
that it's a little deceiving because
people do you know how to fall
relatively safely from from stuff like
that but they get addicted right they're
doing that
probably every - yeah for sure and
there's there's all kinds of different
styles so there's textiles where it's
more people are skating ledges and
benches and you know they flip and
they're bored grinding flipping out
stuff like that where it's low-impact
but super technical and then there's
just the stuntmen who are doing the big
rails the big gaps you know jumping
fences and how did this happen like what
was like how did it go from just riding
escape like when I was a kid
you and I are the same age but when I
was I guess I was probably like 11 or 12
on a skateboard I was just riding it on
the street with all my friends we just
ride a skateboard on the street like
what happened like how did it get to be
like grinding across benches feelings
like I think there's a well there's a
pretty deep history there of how it got
there but skating was yeah just more
like a transportation toy and then it
was really that the Dogtown crew that
took it to a new level where it was like
oh you can use this to do aerials and
skate swimming pools and they were just
trying to emulate their surfing and so
then skate parks started cropping up
skating got popular in the late 70s
early 80s and then it was all swimming
pools and then maybe like four years
later the skateboarding kind of started
falling in popularity the the skate
parks couldn't get their insurance
anymore cuz the liability was crazy and
so then the streets became the skate
park because there's nowhere else to go
and there was this there were a few key
skaters that that figured out how to use
like the urban landscape as a skate park
and then that was it like it was all
bets are off skating kind of took off in
the underground
the street culture a street sport and
then people started doing handrails
ledges benches stairs because they just
didn't have parks
[Applause]